Hey, guys, the new celebration rules are up!
Yeah! We can use the ball as a prop
Yo! We can do group dances
No way! We can dance on the ground
But guys, we still can't do sex moves
OK, G-Men, clearly you need me
To choreograph our celebrations
Now let's show this league how New York City does dance
If we ever score
Well, now hold on—maybe I should be the leader
because I'm uh the Quarterback
Yeah, and where do quarterbacks go?
Behind the linemen
But they can't see me back here
Trust me, it's for your protection
And one, and two and McAdoo!
Step right. Lean back. Giant step left. And shimmy
C’mon, Big Blue, keep it high and tight
Nice, Brandon
Eli, stay in the pocket
Ok now get on the turnpike
And hitchhike left. Now hitchhike right
Come on, Flowers, we need you to get low
Bend those knees
OK now, 2-minute drill
Let's give them that big Broadway finish
With those jazz hands
Let's see those jazz hands, JPP